تعرضت العاصمه الروسيه موسكو للمره
الثانيه منذ بدء الحرب على اوكرانيا لهجوم
بطائرات مسيره وقال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ان الهجمات على المناطق
المدنيه والحيويه هي محاوله لاخافه روسيا
والشعب الروسي في المقابل تعرضت العاصمه
الاوكرانيه لهجوم روسي واسع بالمسيرات هو
ثالث من نوعه خلال 24 ساعه
نتابع تفاصيل تصليحات الصادره من موسكو مع
مدير مكتب الجزيره زاور شاوج والوضع في
كييف وتعليقات اوكرانيا ايضا
نتابعها في
لقاء مع مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود البدايه
مع زاور شاوج من موسكو وتصريحات الرئيس
الروسيه فلاديمير بوتين بشان الهجوم على
العاصمه الروسيه بالمسيره
نعم حسن العاصمه الروسيه مو واستيقظت
باكرا على وقع هجمات بثماني مسيرات تقول
وزاره الدفاع انها مسيارات اوكرانيه تم
اسقاط خمسه منها في ضواحي موسكو عبر
منظومات الدفاع الجوي بانتر وتدميرها
بالصواريخ وثلاثه منها اسقطت فوقها
يعني اطراف العاصمه موسكو باجهزه الحرب
الالكترونيه سقطت بعض اجزائها على بعض
الابنها وتسببت بضرر طفيف استعجلت وزاره
الدفاع او تعجلت وزاره الدفاع والكرملين
ووزاره الخارجيه بتوجيها الاتهامات الى
اوكرانيا وانا المسيرات انطلقت من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وهي من طراز
22 وهي مسيارات تصنعها الشركه اوكرانيه
وقادره على التحقيق لمسافه 800 كيلومتر
فعليا هذه المسافه التي تفصل بين موسكو
واقرب نقطه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه تحت
سيطره الجيش الاوكراني الكرملين اعتبر ان
هذا الهجوم فجاء ردا على استهداف مراكز
صنع قرار مهمه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه افصح
عنها الرئيس الروسي قبل ساعه من الان
عندما قال في تصريحات الصحفيه مقتضبه
تعليقا على هذا الهجوم ان القوات الروسيه
دمرت مركز قياده الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه قبل يومين او ثلاثه ايام على
حد تعبيري وان الرد الاوكراني جاء في
محاوله لاستفزاز الجانب الروسي للقيام
بعمليات مماثله باستهداف على المناطق
الميدانيه قال ان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه
تصدت بشكل مقلوب مقبول لهذه الهجمات ولكن
هناك توجد اشياء يجب العمل عليها دون ان
يدخل في اي تفاصيل اخرى طبعا منذ يومين
تتحدث القوات الروسيه عن ضربات مهمه في
مراكز صنع القرار في اوكرانيا ربما اوجز
اهم ما حدث هناك في مؤتمر الصحفيين اليوم
وزير الدفاع الروسي الذي لخص اهم ضربات
واهم الخسائر التي تكبدت فيها القوات
الاوكرانيه في الشهر الاخير لنتابع سويه
المقاله في هذا الصدد
في كتير بلغت خسائر العدو خلال الشهر
الجاري اكثر من سته عشر الف جنديين و عشره
طائره
و466 مسيره واكثر من 400 دبابه ومركبات
قتاليه مدرعه اخرى كما تم اعتراض والتدمير
196 صاروخا من راجمات ودمرنا مخازن كبيره
للذخيره في مناطق مختلفه ومنظومه للدفاع
الجوي من طراز باتريوت في كييف
اوكرانيا كان لها ايضا تعليق على ما تعرضت
له العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو لكنها هي ايضا تعرضت عاصمتها
لثالث هجوم من نوعه خلال يومين بطائرات
مسيره نتابع ذلك مع حسان مسعود من كييف
حسان
بالفعل حسن العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
استفاقت اليوم على هجمه مكثفه بالمسيرات
الانتحاريه من طراز شاهد التي اطلقت من
عده اتجاهات باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه
السلطات الاوكرانيه تقول ان 31 او 31
مسيره انتحاريه دخلت الاجواء هنا في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه وانها تمكنت وفق قولها
وفق الروايه الرسميه من اسقاط 29 مسيره
منها وهذه المسيرات بهذه الهجمه ادت الى
اضرار بالغه في عدد من المواقع في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه على الاقل خمسه احياء تعرضت
لاضرار اما بسبب سقوط هذه المسيرات او
بسبب حطام المسيرات وتعامل الدفاعات
الجويه معها ادى ذلك ايضا الى مقتل شخص
واصابه ثلاثه اخرين في هذه الهجمه التي
تعتبر هي احدث الهجمات من بين هجمات مكثفه
تتعرض لها العاصمه الاوكرانيه كما ذكرت
ثلاثه هجمات كانت خلال ال 24 ساعه الاخيره
فقط فيما هذه المدينه تتعرض لوتيره
متسارعه بالضربات الصاروخيه وبالمسيرات
منذ بدايه شهر مايو وهي تعرضت لاكثر من
سبعه عشره هجوما خلال هذه
هذا الشهر فقط
وكان خلال الايام الاخيره كان هناك ارتفاع
بالوتيره التي تعرضت بها هذه المدينه وكان
هناك تصريحات لافته لعمده المدينه الذي
كان قد دعى
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
لان يقوم بما يستوجب فعله لكي يعيش سكان
موسكو ما يعيشه سكان كييف بهذه الحرفيه
وبهذه التصريحات عبر عن ذلك من خلال لقاء
تلفزيوني وذلك قبل يوم فقط على الهجمات
التي تعرضت لها العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
كذلك كان هناك
وعود وتوعد وكذلك تهديد من جانب رئيس
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
يوم امس بعد الهجمات الكبيره التي تعرضت
لها العاصمه الاوكرانيه
بالمسيرات والصواريخ كذلك البالستيه قال
ان من يريد ان يهدد اوكرانيا وتحدث عن
نفسه قال من يريد ان يهددنا وهو رئيس
الاستخبارات فان فاننا نريد ان نؤكد له
اننا ما زلنا على راس عملنا وانه سيرى
ردود الافعال قريبا جدا وبعدها حدثت هذه
الهجمات ايضا كان هناك تعليق
للمستشار في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه حول هذه
الهجمات نستمع اليه
في الانغماس في ضباب حرب كبرى لكن فيما
يتعلق بموسكو هذا حدث غير مهم بالنسبه لنا
من الواجب التركيز على الهجمات التي تطال
مدينه كييف فللي اليوم الثالث تشن روسيا
بمختلف انواع الصواريخ الباليستيه
والطائرات دون طيار هجمات لاخافه المدنيين
وزياده الضغط علينا اما بالنسبه للهجوم
على موسكو نحن في عصر الذكاء الاصطناعي
ربما ليست كل المسيلات معده لمهاجمتنا لن
يسمح لروسيا بلعب لعبه احاديه الجانب
لتدمير دوله ذات السياده
شكرا لكم ما حسن مسعود من كييف وزور شاوج
مدير مكتب الجزيره من موسكو